[Music]
sometimes i wonder if i'll ever reach
you
or if now you're just gone for good
if i'll ever see you smile
it's on a again and a therapy but i
won't be there letting you know i care
if i could just break through the glass
for chowders in my hands then it
shatters in my hands
it's a risk i'm willing to take baby i'm
about to break because i can't go on i
can't go on i can't go on i can't keep
pretending that i'm okay
[Music]
watching you slip away
watch you have to go there why do you
want watch you answering questions
whenever i ask you what don't act like
you're so hard to find i
know where you hide why won't you just
stay with me why do you lie why's there
always something keeping you up at night
don't act like you're so hard to find
[Music]
that seemed to tie you with knots
tangled in all you forgot and all you
cannot see is the person who's standing
there
right in front of me
[Music]
if you could only see yourself
watching me slip away
i'm trying to hold these two truths in
my head
both the darkness and the light
please don't expect them no playing nice
[Music]
why won't you just stay with me why do
you why why's there always something
keeping you up at night don't act like
you're so hard to find
why'd you have to go there why
[Music]
why won't you just stay with me
[Music]
[Music]
in the blue house
[Music]
[Music]
you